In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadeon, Per September 26, on which we commemorate the Holy and
Glorious Apostle and Evangelist, John the Theologian.
On the 26th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Glorious Apostle and
Evangelist John the Theologian.
The virgin disciple and beloved friend, who leaned on the Savior's breast, St. John came
from Bethsida, a poor village in Galilee.
He was the Son of Zebedee the Fisherman, and of Salome, the daughter of Joseph, the
betroth of the Mother of God.
Joseph had four sons by his first marriage, James, Joseph's Jude and Simon, or Simeon,
and three daughters, Esther, Martha, and Salome, Thus Jesus Christ our Savior was, according
to the world, the uncle of St. John the Theologian, since he was the half-brother of John's
mother, Salome.
John and his brother, James, were helping their father's Ebedee with the fishing when
the Savior called them to follow him and become fishers of men.
They immediately left everything to follow his heavenly teaching.
Such was John's love of virginity and eschesis, that above all the disciples he was worthy of
the name of virgin, and such his ardent love for Christ and irreproachable life, that among
them all he became the beloved disciple.
So he was one of the three closest to the Savior, who ascended Mount Taber with him.
John looked upon the divinity shining in the body of Christ, and heard the voice out of
the cloud that said, This is my beloved Son, in whom I am well pleased.
Listen to him.
It was John carried away by his love, who wanted to sit on the right hand of the Lord in his
kingdom.
At the mystical supper, the Lord placed him at his side, where he leaned on the breast
of his beloved master.
In the Jews laid hold of Jesus, St. John followed him into the palace of the high priest.
He alone remained with the mother of God at the foot of the cross, when the Savior was crucified.
Seeing John stand by, Christ said to his mother, Woman, Behold your Son, and to John, Behold
your Mother.
And from that hour the virgin disciple took the virgin mother into his own home.
At the time the resurrection was announced, John outran Peter and came first to the Sepulchre.
It was he who first stooped down and saw the linen cloths lying on the ground.
He saw Christ after his resurrection and was commissioned with the other disciples to
preach the glad tidings throughout the earth, when the Lord breathed on them as an earnest
of the gift of the Holy Spirit.
He was present also at the Lord's ascension into heaven and received the Holy Spirit under
the appearance of tongues of fire, with the other disciples on the day of Pentecost.
He remained the last of them all in Jerusalem and the company of the mother of God, whom
he served until the time of her dormitian.
When the time came to part from one another to preach in all the regions of the world, the
apostles drew lots to tell where each should go.
It fell to John to preach the gospel in Asia Minor, which was full of idolatry and entirely
given over to paganism.
St. John was much cast down on learning where he was to go, for he had not yet learned to
put all his trust in the invincible power of God.
To purge him of this human weakness, God put him to the trial of wind and waves for forty
days before he reached his destination.
During this tempest, John's disciple, the Deacon Procarus, was cast by the waves upon the shore
at Salusia, where the people of the city accused him of witchcraft, suspecting him of having
spirited away money from the shipwrecked vessel.
He managed to escape, and after forty days bound his master, whom the sea had brought
ashore, at Marmariotta, another city of Asia Minor.
They made their way to Ephesus where they fell into the hands of a cruel woman called Romana,
who was responsible for the management of baths belonging to the governor, Dios Corrides.
A demon dwelt in these baths, who thrice a year would compass the death of a young man
or maiden.
The two apostles had toiled in slavery there for three months when the demon got hold of
the governor's son Domnos and drowned him.
Romana was distraught and begged John whom she took to be a magician for his help.
The apostle raised the young man from the dead, which led to Romana's conversion, and
he restored Dios Corrides to life also, for he had died of shock, of hearing of his son's
death, and then John baptized all three of them and drove out the demon by his prayer.
The Ephesians had great devotion to the goddess Diana, and from time to time celebrated
high festivals in her honor.
At one of these times John climbed the hill where stood the great statue of the goddess in order
to address the crowd.
The pagans were enraged to see him there and tried to stone him, but by the grace of God,
all the stones missed their mark and struck the statue, which was reduced to rubble by
its votaries.
But the pagans blind to the signs of divine providence and death to the words of St. John
made a second attempt to stone him.
This time the stones turned back on the idolaters themselves and the earth, quaking at the apostles'
prayer, suddenly swallowed up more than 200 of them.
The people who survived came to their senses at last.
They begged John to intercede with God to deal mercifully with them and restore to life
those who had perished.
So, at the prayer of St. John, all those people came forth from the bowels of the earth, venerated
the apostle and were baptized.
As so many people were converted to Christ by John's miracles, the demon that lived in the
temple of Diana assumed the appearance of an imperial official who promised a large reward
to anyone taking captive or killing the two extraordinary powerful magicians who had escaped
his custody.
During the eye of his intelligence, illumined by the Holy Spirit, John knew what the demon
was up to.
Strong in the power of God, he and Prochorus gave themselves up to the pagans who dragged
them to the temple of Diana, which the beloved disciple prayed that the Lord would destroy
without loss of life.
Immediately, that glory of the pagan world collapsed, and by his word alone, John drove out
the demon that had lived there for 249 years to the astonishment of the pagans most of whom
found faith in Christ.
The Emperor Demission in the years 81 through 96 heard of John's renown and arranged to
meet him.
He was so impressed by the apostles' confidence that Christ is mightier than any worldly power
that he banished him to the island of Patmos in the hope of reducing his influence.
On the voyage there with Prochorus, John showed the kindness of God towards man by curing
of dysentery the soldiers escorting them.
As soon as they arrived, he freed Apollonides, the son of Meadon, a local dignitary of an
impure spirit.
This miracle accompanied by the word of John brought Meadon's entire household to faith
in Christ and baptism.
A little later, the governor of the island was also baptized.
A formidable magician known as Kinopsae, which means dogface, wielding all the powers
of Satan, and served by a band of demons, lived in a wild part of the island.
The priests of Apollon who saw John as a dangerous rival appealed to Kinopsae to render the
apostle powerless.
Kinopsae in his pride did not dame to go himself but sent a demon.
John reduced this impure spirit to impotence and drove it from the island in the name of Jesus
Christ as he did all the devils that served the magician.
Relying on the power of illusion, for God alone is able to work miracles, Kinopsae challenged
John to raise a man from the dead, and he himself made a demon appear that resembled
the dead man.
Finally, he challenged the Lord's disciple by diving into the sea, intending to reappear
after a long while.
But at the prayer of John, the sea swallowed him up, as once it had swallowed Pharaoh in pursuit
of Moses.
After that, Kinopsae and his slaves were seen no more on the island.
While he was on Patmos, John received a letter from the Bishop of Athens, Dionysius the
Ariopogite, who was then 99 years old.
He praised John as the day star of the gospel, and prophesied that he would soon be freed.
Indeed, when Trajan succeeded Nerva, in the year 98, he recalled St. John to Ephesus, to
the great sorrow of the people of Patmos, whom he had converted.
John did not want to leave them unconsolved, strengthened by a sign from heaven, he fasted
with them for three days, then accompanied by Prochorus.
He went up into a mountain where he directed all the powers of his soul towards the Lord.
Suddenly, the sky was rent by fearful flashes of lightning and claps of thunder.
Prochorus was overwhelmed and fell to the ground, while John remained impassable in contemplation
for perfect love casts out fear.
He heard a voice like thunder proclaiming from the height of heaven.
In the beginning was the Word, and the Word was with God, and the Word was God.
Prochorus transcribed this message of salvation revealed to John as once the Law to Moses on Mount
Sinai, but this time not for the Jews alone, but for all, even to the ends of the earth.
It was also on Patmos on the Lord's day that John saw in the Spirit Christ, having the appearance
of a young man whose face was like the sun shining in full strength.
The sureing John who fell at his feet as though dead, the Lord said,
fear not. I am the first and the last. I am he that lives and was dead, and behold,
I am alive forever more, and have the keys of death and of hell.
I hate the things that you have seen, and the things which are, and the things which
shall be hereafter.
Then in successive revelations John was shown what will happen at the end of time.
The gathering strength of iniquity, the coming of the Antichrist, his warfare against the
faithful and his final struggle against Christ, who in the end will cast him forever
into hell with the devil and his angels.
It was also given him to see in his vision the violent upheavals that will take place in
the world, the fiery end of all things, and the final triumph of the Son of Man, the general
resurrection and the last judgment.
The book of the Revelation of St. John, which is also the last book of holy scripture, ends
with the sublime vision of the coming forth from God out of heaven, of the celestial Jerusalem,
the holy and eternal city where God will dwell forever with man.
As the bridegroom united with his bride, this city is perfect in its proportions and adorned
as with crystal and fine gold.
Its foundations are garnished with precious stones, and its gates are twelve pearls.
And I saw no temple in the city, St. John records, for its temple is the Lord God Almighty
and the Lamb Christ, and the city has no need of sun or moon to shine upon it for the glory
of God is its light, and its lamp is the Lamb.
Then the beloved apostle, who was accounted worthy of looking upon the mysteries that cannot
be uttered, concludes the book of divine revelations by inviting the faithful to await the coming
of the Savior in silence and prayer.
The Holy Spirit and the bride, that is the church, say, come and let him who hears say, come
and let him who is thirsty, come and take the water of life without price.
Surely, I am coming soon, says the Lord, amen, come, Lord Jesus.
On his way back to Ephesus, John broke his journey at a city called Agriquia, where among
other good works and miracles he converted to Christ a young man, a virtuous disposition
whom he left in the care of the bishop.
When passing through the city sometime later, he learned that the youth had become the
leader of a band of highway men, where upon the aged elder, regardless of danger, took
to the roads and mountains all alone and spared no effort to find him.
It was through giving himself up to the highway men, that he was able to prevail upon the
young man to return through repentance to the way of Christ.
The Beloved Apostle spent the remainder of his days in peace at Ephesus, where he brought
many pagans to the faith.
He was 56 when he left Jerusalem to preach the gospel, which he did for nine years, until
his exile.
He spent 15 years on Patmos and lived another 26 years after his return, so that he lived
in all for 105 years and seven months.
When God made known to him that the hour of his departure from this life was at hand, he
instructed his disciples to dig a grave in the sand in the form of a cross.
Then he embraced and consoled them all and stretched himself out in it, telling them first to
cover him as far as his knees.
After a second farewell, they covered him up to his neck, and just as the sun rose, they
covered his face.
They returned weeping to the city and told the saints other disciples who also wanted
to see his face for the last time.
They went and uncovered the tomb, but it was empty.
This accords with the tradition that Saint John has been raised from the dead and taken up
into heaven, like the mother of God, in fulfillment of the Savior's enigmatic response to Peter's
question about John.
If it is my will that he remain until I come, what is that to you?
His meaning was not that the beloved disciple would not die, but rather that he would wait
the second coming in the special place reserved for him.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.